so we now know that supermassive black
holes inhabit the centres of most if not
all galaxies in the universe for example
the Milky Way harbors a black hole in
the center which is four million times
the mass of the Sun and to just give you
an idea the mass of stars in the Milky
Way is about million times more so while
in the nearby universe black holes like
in the Milky Way are dormant they're
just sitting there in the early universe
black holes are incredibly active
they're active because you have a lot of
matter that's flowing into them that
glows gets heated up and supplies a lot
of energy to the vicinity so this energy
that is supplied by a growing black hole
it turns out is very significant and
shapes galaxies by affecting the amount
of stars that can form in the inner
regions where the black hole sets so it
turns out that in the last two decades
we have now figured out that black holes
fundamentally shape galaxies and
therefore all structure formation in the
universe in fact you could call them
cosmic bullies